[Music]
foreign
well hello there watching The Press
preview a first look at what is on the
front pages time to see what's making
the headlines with the columnist and
broadcaster Steve Richards and the
former conservative special advisor Sal
Michelle great to see both of you as
ever to the front pages first the Metro
has word of a deal between the
government and health unions which would
if NHS staff vote for it give them a
five percent pay rise the eye suggests
it could bring an end to the many
strikes which have taken place in recent
months the express calls it a victory
for common sense and for patients
nurses deal at last that's the front
page of the mirror while the sun simply
says carry on nurse
the time says unions are backing the pay
offer for a million NHS staff because
they're regarded as fair in the wake of
the budget the telegraph says labor is
planning a raid on people's pension Pots
if it wins the next general election and
will scrap the extra relief the
chancellor announced four pensions in
the budget yesterday
the financial times reporting on fears
for banks around the world in the wake
of the collapse of Silicon Valley Bank
and the measures being taken to keep
them afloat the guardian has seen a
report due to be published next week
which is expected to say that the
Metropolitan Police has systemic
problems with racism sexism and
homophobia while the star examines the
sleeping habits of younger people
well a quick reminder by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us so let's head straight to Our
Guest then Steve Richards and Salma Shaw
um Salma NHS deal pay deal all the
details in the papers many people asking
you know parts of this were suggested in
advance like the one-off payment for for
this year why couldn't the government
have done this ages ago
I think that there was definitely that
space that they needed to have in order
to have the negotiation on pay and also
trying to understand uh possibly what
their financial position was as we saw
from the budget this week and I think
you know as as Steve is going to point
out there is still no clarity as to
where this money is going to come from
that is even going to deal with this pay
deal five percent increase and a one-off
payment of a 1 250 pounds so there are
lots of moving Parts in this that I
think didn't necessitate having
um come to this conclusion earlier on
and let's not forget the government
didn't start at the the place that
they've gotten to and certainly for
nurses who were asking for a 19 increase
this is a long way down from what they
had initially started with in terms of
negotiation yes and one Union as we know
out of the 14 negotiating uh with the
the health secretary not recommending
this to their staff uh because it's a
one-off payment although there will be a
permanent 5 pay Rise
um for all effectively for 2023 to 24.
um but Steve as you are going to point
out uh where does the money come from
I think this becomes a key question
because I think Rishi sunak and Jeremy
Hunt in their interviews have sort of
said vaguely well the NHS has got a
generous settlement this year implying
these uh pay Rises will come from that
settlement that there will be no
additional money to pay for it now if
that's the case there will be one of my
favorite words in politics consequences
one of them being that that money that
people assumed was going to be focused
on other things some of it won't be it
will now go towards this pay rise so
it's not entirely clear tonight
where that money is going to come from
but the indications are from the sort of
public comments uh that is going to come
from the existing settlement without
additional funding
but not from patient facing uh work that
the NHS does is what we're being told
this evening Steve
yeah but that it these are very loose
definitions so if not there you know
it's often said oh there can be Savings
in inverted commas no doubt there can be
but whether they can be on this scale
without impacting on uh patient facing
um NHS work is I think uh at least
doubtful and so I think more detail
needs to to come out and there are other
questions why this could not have been
done earlier
um given the fact that um you know once
this proposition was put together
um as you say it's not certain that
people are going to vote for it but you
know given that most unions are
recommending that they do there's been
months of disruption and this could have
been sorted much earlier yes Matthew
Taylor chief executive of the NHS
Confederation one that the Health
Service did not have a couple of billion
pounds lying around to cover the new pay
deal offer suggesting that he thought
the gap between the amount of money the
NHS budgeted spend and how much the
payoffer will cost is around 2 billion
pounds and there'll be more negotiations
we understand between the treasury and
the Department of Health and Social care
um but the newspapers are celebrating to
some extent aren't they the Metro for
example say yes to end the strikes you
know the fact that 13 out of 14 unions
some are recommending this to staff
um partly because they won't have to
wait for for surety of knowledge
um until the industry body recommends uh
what the pay will be and the government
finally accept I think in July last year
so it'll be months of waiting to find
out so they think this this gives staff
at least some confidence in knowing how
they budget them for themselves next
year
yeah and I think this is the thing about
the one-off payment that has been
suggested for the NHS for this year
before the permanent five percent rise
comes in because it is about that whole
thing that we're all sort of talking
about which is the cost of living crisis
and even though the government's now got
an inflation under control well
inflation has come under control
um there is still that uh question that
prices actually don't fall as a
consequence of it they just slow so
there is that sort of worry that's
probably going to be in a lot of
people's minds about how they are going
to you know fulfill paying for their
energy bills and their shopping costs
Etc but I I would just say that you know
alongside that sort of inflationary
prediction you know I can see why the
government wanted to consider you know
everything in the round before they
settled on this pay deal and I think the
reason why newspapers are quite positive
about it is because we want to we all
want to feel like there's going to be
some good news
um at the end of this especially with
public services where so many people are
dependent Healthcare
uh yes uh Union's back Fair raise for a
million NHS staff ballots in next month
on this five percent pay rise uh it's
not over though is it plenty of
industrial action is still out there
Steve including the suggestion possibly
that uh passport staff might go on
strike too so you know are you do you
sense a change in mood that people are
coming to you know settlements now and
everybody wants this over well not yet
um I mean I don't know how all your
weekend plans are being affected mine's
been completely disrupted by the train
action on uh Saturday and others will be
in the same position and if you just you
know I've just heard about this passport
threat so
um no I mean this could go one of two
ways and I genuinely don't know which
way it will go
um that uh others note that they have
reached a settlement and others try and
do the same quite quickly
um or
um and this happened a lot in the 70s
unions say well hold on a second they've
got this deal um what about us
um and so I I'm not at all sure tonight
this means it's the end of these uh
waves of stripes
um the Ft as well and it just strikes on
hold after unions agree to recommend a
payoff for to members
um and they do have they are reporting
here that more than a thousand workers
in passport offices in England Scotland
and Wales plan to walk out for five
weeks in April and May that's according
to the PCS Union uh so the paper
reporting that news there and at the sun
um Selma carry on Nurse Health unions
last night back to five percent pay rise
for next year they halted strike action
the deal also gives NHS staff a two
percent rise on last year's settlement
um do you think they'll say yes staff
what's your feeling
well I hope so because it's backed by
you know union leaders you know
presumably there is confidence as a
result of that that this is a fair deal
and you know as you pointed out the
times leads with that word fair that the
union
um leaders have decided that this is
what they can get at this present moment
in time but just to build on Steve's
point about you know the continuation of
strikes indeed there is an issue within
the NHS because Junior doctors don't
seem to be part of this and whilst
they're being asked to hold off on
further strikes this does not
um include them this is Nurses nurses
pay deal but the strikes in lots of
other areas aside from the passport
office are not negotiations with the
government so rail strikes for example
on negotiations with a private company
which the government does not have the
same kind of Leverage over and certainly
the teachers strike as well is going to
be something that comes back so we are
going to have to wait and see whether
this means that there is going to be
certainty and Clarity for the rest of
the year or whether this is is just
going to create more tension in those
other areas in the public sector where
the government does have some say on
that on that pay deal yes we have to
remember that the majority of schools in
England closed their doors to some
pupils during teacher strikes uh you
know over two days tens of thousands of
members of the National Education Union
uh walking out for two consecutive days
of strike action on Wednesday and
Thursday this week in that long run
dispute overpaid too I think they were
asked weren't they to suspend strikes in
England but they said that the Neu
refused until the education secretary
made a payoff for which could end this
the dispute so that's still ongoing
meantime a quote from the GMB National
secretary Steve Rachel Harrison saying
the government had gone from refusing to
talk about pay this year to putting an
extra 2.5 billion pounds on the table
GMB members should rightly be proud of
themselves it's been a tough road but
they face down the Department of Health
and won an offer that we feel is the
best they can be achieved at this stage
through negotiation
um the point I suppose is that inflation
is falling uh you know from about
mid-year onwards isn't it
and we seem to be getting the figure of
the cost of this uh 2.5 billion 2.2
billion according to Matthew Taylor and
remember the extra money
this has already been announced for the
NHS was meant to be meeting the huge
Backlot that arose over covid it's meant
to be dealing with staff shortage crises
um now suddenly two billion of it is to
apparently uh meet the cost of this pay
demand and um you know so I I think the
the implications of that are pretty big
I mean it's quite a big sum two billion
uh 2.5 billion and it looks as if it's
not going to come from the government in
terms of additional money okay well
we'll see what happens when it's
presented to staff keep an eye on what
they do and elsewhere in industrial
action as well but let's move on to the
front of the financial times uh talking
about Banks and two big things today as
they said struggling banks on both sides
of the Atlantic were racing to reassure
clients first of all Credit Suisse
Executives spent the day calling clients
to reassure them that it had been shored
up and secondly another bank in the
United United States being propped up by
the Big Wall Street lenders to the tune
of 30 billion dollars so lots of money
being pummeled into these uh into the
banking sector
um uh Salma do you think do you think
reassurance is the name of the game
right now
well absolutely and if you if you're
reading the Ft piece uh which is
obviously sort of the go-to newspaper
for the financial World
um a very sort of big Financial called
Larry Fink who who runs a big hedge fund
uh is talking about the fact that this
is going to be an issue of confidence
and it's probably too soon to liken it
to the last financial crash but I think
that experience being so sort of fresh
in people's memories is definitely going
to be somewhere but people draw
comparisons and it is about what happens
with smaller Banks and the fact that
um you know the Silicon Valley bank now
Credit Suisse now another bank in the US
is facing this kind of run on its
deposits so we are now having to watch
and wait and see actually whether there
is Contagion from what's happening in
these small Banks to some of the bigger
institutions and what that is actually
going to mean for the average person not
just businesses that have invested yeah
all sorts of high-level meetings today
in Switzerland with the Swiss government
and their regulator and their National
Bank the FED in America watching Credit
Suisse uh JP Morgan Chase one of those
banks that drove the support for the
first um uh the the American Bank that
was propped up today also commenting
Steve on Credit Suisse uh analysts there
saying that the latest developments at
Credit Suisse meant the status quo was
no longer an option and a
state-sponsored merger with UBS was a
likely solution UBS indicating it's not
so happy about that suggestion but you
know these these banks are being propped
up to the tune of tens of billions of
dollars now
yeah and they do have I remember so well
I'm not saying you know it's going to
happen uh again but it does have Echoes
of that early period in the build up to
the 2000 note financial crash where you
heard about relatively obscure banks at
the beginning uh failing in some form or
another and needing to be rescued in
some form or another and Osama suggested
the key word here is Contagion in two
different forms whether it spreads to
other Banks and whether investors Panic
has seemed to have happened to some
extent already
um now on the upside you could say well
rescue packages have been quickly put
into place
um but to some extent to be honest at
the beginning of the 2008 crash that
happened do you remember in this country
the year before that crash nor the rock
got into deep trouble
um but the government moved in and and
and took it over in effect
um so you know who knows what's going to
happen uh next but it is it is a nerve
fee moment but that last crash Gordon
Brown described it as the first crisis
of the global economy because it's
spread across the world and obviously if
that were to happen again you know we're
in deep deep trouble but um I mean it
feels like we have with the pandemic and
the energy crisis from the war in
Ukraine it feels like we've we've had a
few crises does it not but um 54 billion
dollars for Credit Suisse 30 billion
dollars for this First Republic Bank and
still the European Central Bank decided
to increase interest rates
um today you know we've got decision
next week here will it will it slow the
path of interest rate increases do you
think what's happened Selma
potentially I mean it's I I I'm not an
economist so I wouldn't want to try and
predict what the bank of England's going
to do in terms of interest rates but I
also think that one of the difficulties
about this is that you know when you are
talking about an issue of confidence and
consumer confidence and when you're
looking at the fiscal picture that we've
just had from the budget it does give
you a sense of sort of nervousness about
you know what exactly governments and
International in the international
monetary fund and international central
banks could do given all these other
pressures that they've just had you know
whether it is the pandemic or war in
Ukraine and all the pressures that that
is putting on Supply chains you know how
much money is there really around there
to be able to bail out Banks again so I
think this is this is going to be kind
of one of those things that's sitting in
the back Bank of Financial Centers
across the world is is kind of you know
are we going to maintain that confidence
and he's plugging the gaps in the way
that the treasury did with the UK branch
of svb over the weekend quite
successfully is that going to be enough
or you know is it as Steve says you know
kind of reminiscent of what happened
with Northern rock all those years ago
um it's not something that I can predict
unfortunately if I if I could I'd
probably you know be be somewhere else
working in the city probably but um I
think this is kind of a very nervous
moment for a lot of um people in the
sector you'd be George Soros or
something like that wouldn't you I'm
probably not talking to us at this point
Selma Steve say they're a lot more stuff
yes exactly lots more still to discuss
including after the break more on the
Downing of an American drone by a
Russian fighter jet and the news of jets
are potentially going to Ukraine too uh
back with that in just a moment
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Steve
Richards and Sal Michelle welcome back
to both of you uh certainly some
dramatic pictures on the front pages and
inside two of the footage released today
of uh the moment these two Russian Jets
over the Black Sea uh downed this U.S
drone Steve amazing picture there as you
can see
um now Russia denied it
um we we now know not to believe Russia
again don't we
yeah and I gather these drones contain
sensitive information and
um and as you say the pictures are very
dramatic and it's an example really of
how things seem to be escalating
um sometimes we've done this uh press
preview when
um it looked as if Ukraine was on the
edge of some sort of decisive Triumph
but even then I was supposed to question
well what formed as victory take and
what formulas defeat take for Russia and
actually what you're seeing here is uh
and by the way on the another page on
the Metro where they've got these photos
there's talk of uh you know American
sources saying Putin would be willing to
press the nuclear trigger now again who
knows you have to be in his mind maybe
he himself isn't fully in his mind
um but it just shows this is going to go
on and on for a long time and we know
ukrainians neighbors have taken this
very seriously uh James cleverley and
Moldova today and also the polls which
makes the the front of the financial
times uh being the first effectively to
break ranks and offering the ukrainians
MiG-29 fighter jets
um oh sorry that's a MiG-29 fighter jet
which takes part in a NATO exercise in
Poland last October but the decision to
go It Alone
um has been extraordinary hasn't it for
Poland which has been a staunch Ally
certainly of the ukrainians
it's almost muted I think are you
sorry can you hear me now yes I can
sorry yeah sorry I think the interesting
thing about this is that obviously we
have
um as you say this break from NATO of
Poland because obviously they are so
close to to the action they are on the
border and they are getting an influx of
refugees I think they're seeing so so
much more of the first uh the impact
first hand of this war and we are still
all slightly distanced from it I think
what's fascinating about this is that
obviously the ukrainians want American
jets
um they're not trained to fly American
jets I think this would put them back in
terms of being able to achieve what they
want to but you're right this could be
seen as a big escalation but having the
American jets coming over I think would
be a bigger issue for Russia and what's
going to happen in terms of the the
stepped increase in this conflict so
whilst Poland is breaking away from it I
think within that
um sending of the Jets over to Ukraine
there is a Nuance that at least they're
not American jets and therefore hoping
that it's not going to be the same level
of escalation if that had taken place
yes in the words of the the Polish
president Andres Duda in the coming days
were handing over four aircraft in full
working order adding that an unspecified
number of additional jets would be sent
later
um and as you said analysts suggesting
that f-16s us-made f-16s would require
months of training and uh you know they
need it now don't they
um head to the Delhi staff for a final a
bit of news which is that our young
people are exhausted Steve
yeah well I'm feeling pretty fresh now
you know and so and I'm very youthful so
I I don't fit that headlight actually
apparently we do because if we're
feeling lively that's what our
generation is all about and it's these
young people who can't keep up
um because they're sleeping all the time
it explains a lot explains our low
productivity level in Britain come on
we're still wrong 24 year olds many who
haven't entered the workplace anyway
apparently Generation Z half of
generations you have at least one nap a
day 17 of under 24s are so tired they
need to doze off twice let's hope
they're not right now and